to india where new corona virus
infections hit a daily record of
184 372.
now hardest hit is the country's
economic engine the
state of maharashtra and its capital
mumbai
here a lockdown aims to curb the spread
of infections but it also cripples
businesses and those struggling to make
ends meet
this fish is rotting and its struggling
owner
at this deserted mumbai market is fed up
not even one rupees worth of fish was
sold today i came at 8 30 in the morning
and i still haven't earned a thing
look can you see any customers anywhere
the city is the capital of one of
india's richest and most
industrialized states and leader of the
country's exploding covert 19 resurgence
now a tight lockdown has been extended
to weekends some say it's choking
businesses and livelihoods
india's largest bullion market has
already suffered a loss of 8.1 billion
dollars in the last 10 months
and if the government now imposes
weekend lockdown then we will suffer a
huge loss in the festive season
lockdown should be done in such a way
that the common man is not affected
economically
people have children and families that
they need to feed
the impact on the broader economy has
been considerable too
industrial output contracts fell 3.6
in february faster than expected and
giving fuel to concerns that the economy
is slowing
other states in india haven't
implemented a lockdown
and now there are fears that unless this
second wave is brought under control
fast
it could dash hopes of a swift recovery
in one of the world's fastest growing
economies
now for more let's bring in dw's nidi
rai in mumbai which of course
is india's financial and commercial hub
and the capital of the state of
maharashtra
uh niti how big an impact does the
lockdown there have on
india's economy as a whole
so maharashtra as you said is the
financial hub of the country and if we
put a lockdown in maharashtra
a rating which is a rating agency in
india they have come out with an
estimate which says that it is going to
cost
the gdp 5.3 billion dollars
and this is just the impact if you put a
lock down for a
for a 15 day time period so you can just
exfoliate
it and you can understand that how
important maharashtra is for the indian
gtp
of course people need to make a living
we've seen it in this report and it
seems that that
is one of the main drivers of this new
wave hasn't the indian government handed
out aid to support businesses so that
people can stay at
uh home ever since the covet pandemic
hit the country
uh from september onwards the indian
government kept
coming out with different kind of fiscal
stimulus programs where they tried
pushing the
msme sector they tried pushing the job
sector they tried helping people
in in they tried extremely poor people
again getting some money
and all this costed us around half a
trillion dollar
but uh the what the experts say is this
that the money which the government has
pumped into the economy has not
reached the grassroots level therefore
the impact of all the fiscal stimulus
which the government has given has not
been seen
as such and then the second wave came so
therefore
the government is trying to help but
it's not working out right now
what about vaccination i mean india is
after all a major
vaccine maker when will this help curb
the spread of the virus there
that's a very interesting question india
has administrated
on around 100 million doses until now
right now as we speak the the problem is
this that india already had two vaccines
the biggest manufacturer as we all know
that the syrian institute is based out
of india
but then the syrum institute has said
that they are facing a very difficult
time because there is lot of pressure on
their production capacity
the government has already allowed the
third the sputnik
from russia to be expo to be imported in
india
but obviously because we are 1.4 billion
people
the population is really large and 16
states the 16 biggest states of the
country
are showing an upside trajectory right
now so answering that question would be
really difficult but right now there is
a huge shortage of vaccine in the
country itself
people are questioning the government's
decision of exporting we have almost
exported 64 million
doses to almost 70 countries so people
are questioning that
you have not given us the dose and you
have sent it out so that
that's a very difficult answer to give
right now okay dw's needy right there
reporting from mumbai thank you
you